today's starting pitcher for the tigers
is yvonne nova
he's a pros pro right he's the guy
that's going to throw the ball over he's
going to try to get you deep into the
ball game
jorge if solaire steps in that's oh
man that ball is crushed deep right
center field and off the wall that is a
long way from home plate and jorge soler
has a one-out double salvador perez
and that's hit well center field deep
and jones fades back to make the play
solaire
read it right away that jones was going
to make the play so he'll move to third
base
and ryan o'hearn cleaning things up hit
to the left side and through that's a
base hit
so lair will score and the royals take
the early one-nothing lead
here's miguel cabrera
sends it to deep right way back at the
wall
see ya there you go right on cue
and miguel cabrera's timing was just
fine right there
1-1 we were talking before the game chef
and i mentioned i said nikki needs to
send a message to this kid
you know typically young pitchers that
face a future hall of famer for the
first time
you know they're going to challenge them
there's always that i'm better than you
and i'm going to beat you
it looked like it had some slider spin
but [ __ ] got the barrel out
america park in detroit it's a 1-1 score
and yvonne nova goes after alex gordon
who rips one down the line
that ball into the corner rattles around
alex races to second base and has
himself
a two base hit francie cordero
that is back through the middle so
cordero
picks up monday alex gordon's lead off
double turns into a run and the royals
lead 2-1
and that'll bring up adelberto mondesi
the fastball grounded through the hole
on the left side they had the overshift
on
batting left-handed he punched it
through the left side where there was
only one infielder
there he goes again swung on and foul
tipped
really good pitch obviously might need
some new pants
i think he ripped the seat of his pants
on that slide
is there a seamstress in the house no
no i can answer that right now thank
goodness for sliding shorts
they don't make uniforms like they used
to right jack scope do up for the tigers
here in the fourth
pokes it to deep left back goes gordon
come on
jonathan scope just one arm that ball
over the left field wall for his third
homer of the year
oh that's a beauty to tie to two what is
with these tigers
home runs are just coming
this is a slider he used two hens to
make contact
that lead hand came off the swing but he
barreled it up
and jacoby jones
jones throws his bat down and
cordero makes a tremendous play in right
field
it was a heck of a catch too and the way
to stay with it
he caught it in the heel of his glove
lots of times that's a dead part of it
player's glove
and it didn't pop out nice play for him
the 1-1 oh there goes the bat lookout
under the top of the tiger dugout on the
third base side
chamber candelaria went running for
cover
three infielders on the left side of the
infield for solaire here comes the 0-1
and a swing and a shot to right field
that's going to be in for a hit
over to play it as mabin whitmerfield
going around second he's into third
so lair will pull up at second with a
double and they're at second and third
with a real opportunity with salvador
perez coming up
1-0 in the pitch and salvia will ground
it toward the middle the second baseman
as a wit is breaking for home he scores
throw over to the lead runner solaire
the third baseman candelaria will tag
him out
so whit was going on contact he scores
solaire is out and salvi will be the
runner at first with now two down but
the royals take the lead 3-2
so one out and alex gordon is the batter
and now a line drive base hit by alex
who's now three for four tonight
alberto monteci has a two-hit game
former come set
brings the pitch and it is hit hard into
right field that's a base hit
backing it up as cameron mabin fires
into the infield gordon goes all the way
around a third and holding it first is
modesty
and this is bubba starling's first
at-bat it's down to the count 0-1 wants
to stay away from the strikeout got to
make contact
the pitch a swing and a shot down the
line
that's a base hit bubba starling comes
through
gordon scores monteci to third base
and monday will score a huge hit by
bubba starling
with a strike on him he doubles down the
left field line
miguel cabrera got the tigers on the
board back in the first kennedy delivers
this one to left gordon will watch it
sail away
another solo homer for cabrera
two on the night third for the tigers
tonight and everybody gets
curly fries through jacoby jones
pulled on the ground to franco and his
throw is
in time and the royals break through in
the later innings
you